hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carrol as a working scientist one of the
things that I've had to do over the
years is apply for grant money and for
theoretical physicists this is a funny
thing because you're supposed to say not
only what you're interested in the topic
you're going to be working on but what
achievements you will have what progress
you will make this is very difficult to
do as a theoretical physicist you don't
know what's going to happen before you
do it as an experimenter you can at
least say what experiment you will build
and when you will turn it on what you
hope to see but of course experimenters
also don't know exactly what they're
going to see this is not only for
theoretical physicists um there are
kinds of experiments or observations
where you can say what you're going to
do but the outcome is so unpredictable
that it's actually kind of hard to wrap
your brain around what would happen
under different circumstances one of
those examples is is the search for
extraterrestrial life I'm one who
believes that it is plausible that we
will find life elsewhere in the universe
and also we are not ready for that
science fiction authors have thought
about the discovery of alien life for a
long time mostly I have to say mostly in
unrealistic ways and I don't blame them
you know they want to tell good stories
so they very often have
structures of intelligence and
technology and
civilizations amongst the aliens that
might be a little bit higher or a little
bit lower than ours but are at least
recognizable right a Galactic Empire as
soon as you say the words galactic
Empire you kind of know what you have in
mind it's not a coincidence that Star
Wars is basically a western or basically
some kind of Samurai film right now
there's more sophisticated science
fiction than Star Wars but still it's
just hard as human beings to wrap
ourselves wrap our brains around the
idea of what would an alien civilization
be like that is a billion years more
advanced than we are and that's very
possible that that's what we find either
a billion years more advanced or a
billion years less advanced in terms of
evolutionary time scale in which case
it's little tiny organisms that we can't
really have a conversation with and I
don't really think that we as a species
have thought this through because it's
easy to dismiss it as kind of science
fictiony right science fiction authors
have talked about looking for in finding
alien life for a long time so we
associate it with science fiction not
with serious science this is a point
made by today's guest Adam Frank Adam is
an astrophysicist at the University of
Rochester he has a new book out called
simply the little book of aliens and he
explains in the podcast how not too long
ago the entire field of as astrobiology
was just considered fringy it was just
considered too speculative you couldn't
get any money to do it Etc and this is
even if you just thought about how do we
do the chemistry and the geology and the
so forth to allow life to exist on other
environments what you would think I hope
now is a very straightforward scientific
question that we've already talked about
on the podcast but there is also the
possibility that we find not only
unicellular life somewhere out there in
the universe but intelligent life and
it's hard to remove the connotations or
associations with UFO conspiracy
theorists and things like that um but we
should because it's an important thing
that could actually happen to us of
course maybe it won't there's the famous
fairy Paradox that says there should
have been aliens that we could easily
detect already but there hasn't been so
it's very possible that there just
aren't any technologically advanced
civilizations out there in the world
world but we should keep an open mind
about this I think it's also very
plausible that there will be so that's
what we're talking about in today's
podcast we're going to talk about what
kinds of aliens there could be how you
would go look for them trying to
separate the seriousness from the less
serious ways of talking about this and
best of all we will let you in on how
real working scientists think about UFOs
and Associated controversies so with
that let's
go
[Music]
Adam Frank welcome to the mscap podcast
Sean it's great to be here so you've
written a book about aliens a little
book because I guess we haven't
discovered them yet I'm hoping that
after we discover them the big book will
be forthcoming well the the book was
little because what I I really wanted
was to give I wanted to write a book
that was accessible as possible to as
broad an audience as possible um you
there's some obvious reasons so lots of
people will buy it but more than that
right now the question of life in the
universe is one that gets so much
attention both because of the scientific
advances but more because of what the
hype that sort of goes around with UFOs
and uaps and I wanted people to have a a
fun fast uh uh entry into everything
that's happening both in that subject I
took on that subject but more
importantly what's happening with things
like the James web Space Telescope
what's happening at the frontiers of
astrobiology because that's really the
exciting part we're we may be the last
generation that doesn't know the answer
to the question are we alone yeah I mean
that's the nice thing about the subject
right is that you're talking about real
science maybe it's not the nice thing
but a things that there's real science
as well as a little bit of
sensationalism and and we'll get into
that
let me just start by orienting ourselves
here like what kind of aliens are we
talking about here um not in the UFO
sense but there are extraterrestrial
life forms there could be
extraterrestrial life forms that are
just single cell organisms there could
be ones that are at least comparable to
our technological level or there could
be ones that are posthuman in some sense
and almost unimaginable to us right like
do we do you personally have a Target in
mind when you think about aliens um all
of them I think all of them are should
be considered as part of the search
because the amazing thing now is we have
the capacity to find all of them right
you know when people we talk about
aliens exactly there's this sense of
like oh unless it's an alien
civilization no one's interested right
if we found evidence of a microbial
biosphere it wouldn't be interesting and
I reject that entirely I think for you
know deep philosophical his historical
and scientific reasons the discovery of
any kind of Life anywhere would be other
than Earth would be the greatest
scientific discovery in the history of
humanity so the important thing is we
have the capacity to find biospheres
which is the um signatures of just
microbial or forests or you know things
that don't build civilizations we have
the capacity now through techno
signatures to find technos spheres
evidence of a technology of
civilizations producing technology and
then you know when we get to the truly
High scales yeah those things should
also be that's a little bit more in the
realm of of traditional SE um but yeah
we have the capacity to find those as
well so I think what really people need
to understand is we didn't have these
capacities like even 10 years ago and
now suddenly uh the telescopes and the
detectors have gotten to the point to be
able to find these bio and techno
signatures and NASA's all in the whole
scientific Community is all in which was
not true again even 10 20 30 years ago
so sorry what about say more about that
transition about being Allin that wasn't
there 10 or 20 years ago well as you
know I have a whole section in the book
about chapter in the book about the
giggle Factor as we call it we in the
business call it because even when I was
a graduate student way back late ' 80s
and early 9s right um you know SEI there
was only seti right there astrobiology
was not a thing right
the Viking Landers had pretty much kind
of closed the door on life on Mars uh
because of those experiments that were
done and there was only SEI and SEI was
still kind of uh marginal it was very
marginalized right we had one professor
at the University of uh University of
Washington where I was a PhD student who
was into it Woody sullan and he was the
only one and you know everybody loved
Woody but there was just this General
sense cuz he was a great side he was a
radio scientist but there was always
this sort of sense of oh that's
marginalized right that's something
that's not you know certainly don't do
that for your career right don't make SI
a choice and that I think held for quite
a while and then after 1995 we get the
first discovery of exoplanets we get
that Martian uh meteorite which looked
like it might have had evidence for life
didn't but that launched like the new
era of astrobiology and starting from
that point NASA starts putting money
into astrobiology by the first decade of
of the new uh century
there are astrobiology centers um by the
time you get to the you know 10 years
ago we now have a full census of exop
planets we know that know that every
planet in the sky has a family of Worlds
orbiting it every fifth star sorry every
I'm sorry what I meant to say was every
star in the night sky has a PL a family
of planets and every fifth star has a a
planet in the uh habitable zone in the
right place for life to form so and most
importantly as I'm sure we'll talk more
about this process of atmospheric
characterization where there was we
figured out a way to look into the
atmospheres of these worlds that are 40
light years away and detect their
composition and therefore be able to
find signatures of microbial life or you
know signatures of a biosphere or
signatures of a technosphere that kind
of that propelled everything that
changed everything and now the you know
last year the astronomy or two years ago
the astronomy decadal survey was
announced where you know all of
astronomers got together and decided
what the next big project should be and
the it's it's there in the name the next
big telescope is going to be the
habitable world's Observatory so you
know the giggle factor is over there's
still some issues about techn signatures
versus bio signatures that's very much
my thing right now but even that is we
find we're overcoming that so it's I you
know the scientific communities all in
on the search for Cosmic life there is a
weird analogy to the foundations of
quantum mechanics in that in both cases
it was something people talked about for
decades there was Giggles there were
Giggles about it it was kind of fringy
but then what is changing is that
technology is forcing us to confront
some things and suddenly oh yeah okay
now you're allowed to talk about it yeah
that's I think that's a great uh analogy
right because it was quantum information
science and the idea that oh quantum
computers where you have to swallow the
um the superp positions whole that
suddenly people were like what's this
superposition again and so I think
that's a really nice analogy it was the
technology the ability to First detect
exoplanets that was a major Revolution
and then now once we got really good
with the transit method which is where
you find exoplanets by watching the star
or the planet pass between you and the
star and there's a few moments there or
maybe an hour where the light passes
through the planet's atmosphere and you
can you can look at the absorption
spectra all the C you know the the
fingerprints that come from uh chemicals
in the atmosphere hitting the light
that's what did it and so now suddenly
and we're still on the hairy Edge like
jwst is just at the edge we might if
we're lucky be able to get a bio
signature I mean that would be amazing
um but it's going to be the next
telescopes the 30 meter class telescopes
and then the habitable world's
Observatory that's really going to put
us in there my impression is that
jwst wasn't actually conceptualized as
something that was looking for
habitability of exoplanet it was kind of
designed to look at distant galaxies but
then turns out to be good for it so it's
kind of not surprising that if you
purpose build a telescope it would be
able to do a much better job yeah that's
it and then so it is actually lucky that
the jwst was has the right bands the the
the um spectral bands that it's looking
for that actually are overlap in with
many of the uh regions we think these
bio and techno signatures may live in so
for example there was just this really
interesting Discovery a couple of about
a month ago where this entirely new
class of habitable planet which we what
we call a hean world hydrogen ocean
world uh uh was had its atmosphere
characterized in a way that actually
indicated yeah this is so let me just
explain a hean world is it's a sub
Neptune so it's a planet that's maybe
eight times the mass of the Earth pretty
big and normally You' think that would
look like Neptune or Uranus you know
which was a world that
maybe has a rocky core and then just
slushes and ices and then hydrogen
helium at the not a good place for life
but they have figured out that there's
this possibility of a world that has a
pretty thick hydrogen atmosphere and
hydrogen's a very good greenhouse gas so
what you could have below it if you have
enough water is a liquid ocean a warm
liquid ocean so this is you this
hydrogen ocean worlds and this is an
what's so exciting to me at least this
is an entirely new class of habitable
worlds world right we always think oh
you need an earth and it needs to be in
the habitable zone yada yada and this is
this is an entirely crazily different
kind of world and the
jwst was able to find methane in the
atmosphere characterize methane in the
atmosphere at like the five Sigma level
so very strong detection and then also
CO2 I think at like the three and a half
Sig uh Sigma level so that really meant
and and those levels were enough to say
like oh yeah this is what we think if
it's if there's a liquid ocean down like
those levels were fit exactly what the
models predicted so there's an example
of the jwst doing atmosphere character
at a very high level um and getting us
information even if it didn't have an
actual bio signature there there were
some like there was a little indication
of um uh what is it dimethyl sulfide
which is what Plankton fart into the
atmosphere um but that was nobody really
believed that for sure even the authors
were like look we're just saying we see
a little wiggle there um but it was
showing that jwst is is is there for
getting at least certain kinds of
exoplanet information that we need so I
wouldn't get into the um actual
technological capabilities of of us in
detail later but but first I do want to
lay the groundwork about this um what we
might be able to find in the sense that
like we said there's primitive life
there's human comparable life and
there's Way Way Beyond human and I think
that one thing that people don't seem to
quite internalize in this discussion is
the chances that any life we would find
are at the human compatible level are
almost nil in my view just because it's
very easy for a planet to have been
evolving for either a billion more years
than us or a billion less years than us
yeah and actually we uh David Kipping
and I and um Caleb sharp did a paper a
few years back where David did all the
basy and Kung Fu to show that uh you
know uh we called it I think contact
inequality
that basically if you detect somebody
odds are they're older than you you know
for a whole bunch of reasons and um you
know that was it was one of the first
places like okay I really got to
understand basan statistics but it was a
very nice paper and the result was
pretty clear that as you say it's just
it sort of confirms an intuition that
odds are you're not going to find
somebody at your level of Technology you
know in order to to if you're going to
find them they probably had to exist a
long time like if they only exist 200
years good luck unless they're very
unless there's a lot of civilizations
like so in general you're going to find
somebody much older than you so yeah and
we've only had techno signatures we've
only been a technological a
technologically detectable civilization
for you know a hundred years maybe so
it's just unlikely that you're going to
find someone at our level which is what
makes all a lot of the UFO stuff kind of
a little bit ridiculous um because this
seems to be so close to our Technologies
well and if the civilizations don't just
blow themselves up which is certainly
one of the options on the table do we
even have sensible Notions of what they
would be what they would be like or is
that kind of just hopeless to speculate
about no actually this is we're working
on a paper on this right now the whole
idea so uh you know in the book I talk
about this this NASA Grant we got I'm
the principal investigator on this uh
the first grant NASA has ever given for
atmospheric techno signatures you know
as as you know I recount the history in
the book because it's important of this
because I said because of the giggle
Factor there was basically no funding
for especially from NASA and NASA tried
a couple times to fund you know at a
very low level some some uh Ste work and
Congress somebody in Congress twice or
three times stood up and said we're not
going to waste money on these finding
lre men and killed it so NASA you know
is a government agency and they learned
like we don't we're not going here
anymore and so it's literally in the
call for propos proposals in these
astrobiology programs to like no we
don't want they were like we don't want
SE no radio set so when we finally
managed to get this grant through which
was like not radio setti but was using
you know things like the jwst to find
Atmosphere techos signatures that was a
big deal and one of the things we said
was we are also we're going to look you
know we're going to make a library of
possible techno signatures but we're
also going to try and push the field
forward right and this has been a
problem with seti is that most of it is
in the grade literature right there's or
or you know conference proceedings
there's there's never been a continuous
coherent um ongoing back and forth
between the literature and then the next
thing you want to do because it was
never a coherent Community it was just
brave souls doing it on their own so one
of the things so so to get back to your
question one of the things we're doing
right now is to try and systematize
Futures right we're actually taking um
uh methods from what's called future
studies which has been applied to
climate change and trying to apply these
to technos signes what if anything can
you say might be generic about the
evolution of
civilizations and it's been an
interesting project to because you got
to map out the spaces right you're never
going to be able to predict Futures
you're going to be able to predict like
the fans of trajectories like the wide
range of trajectories and so I think if
you focus on things like energy use you
know trying to focus on the physical
aspects not the sociological aspects
then you can sort of map out
questions like do they have Interstellar
travel do they have faster than light
travel do they have you know and so you
can at least begin to get a sense of
what those uh what those parameters look
like and the nice thing of course
because the second second law of
Thermodynamics is your friend right no
matter what happens I doubt the second
law thermodynamics is going to be
overcome so therefore that is going to
leave imprints on your planet and and on
your you know your solar system so I
think that's a very using the second law
of Thermodynamics which is what the
Dyson spheres are all about is is a good
way of saying of guiding your intuition
about what these civilizations and what
the imprints will leave let's not
imagine that everyone here knows what a
Dyson Sphere is or the second law of
Thermodynamics so how do those things
help us look for life elsewhere yeah
okay so what is a civilization it's
really just a mechanism for harvesting
energy and putting it to work um and you
know like human beings 300,000 years ago
basically every day every human being
had one human being worth of power right
you know you know there's horsepower and
there's human beings but as as we
progressed working together we were
slowly able to harvest more energy so
that right now I had to do this
calculation once each of us has the
equivalent in our house just our house
alone of about between 50 and 100 human
beings at work for us just from you know
the power coming through the outlet so
the the very famous second law of
Thermodynamics tells us that if you want
to use energy to do work you're going to
create waste of some version you know
could be waste could be just heat you
know random motions of atoms but you can
generalize that to mean you're just
going to create crap there's going to be
noise there's going to be you know
there's just going to be a consequence
of trying to harvest that energy and use
it for work so one of the so this is a
great thing to think about for alien
civilizations because they civilizations
are going to be harvesting energy it's
the very definition in the definition so
a long time ago back in 1960 Freeman
Dyson very smart physicist realized that
um one way uh one one one thing you can
consider that might be Universal in the
trajectory of civilizations would be to
harvest as much energy as possible from
the your solar system and that means
your star you would try and surround the
entire star with solar collectors get
all that energy and do whatever you want
to do with it whatever you're interested
in doing it so the idea was to build a
Dyson Sphere a sphere around the star
that had solar collectors inside uh now
he knew immediately that was UN
gravitationally unstable so really these
days we think about Dyson swarms you
know just these giant plane sized
machines that are solar panels that are
orbiting the star now the thing about
that is if you do that you collecting
energy you're going to some by by the
action of collecting and harvesting that
energy you are going to create waste
heat you're going to warm up basically
and you should be visible in the
infrared the whole thing should be
glowing the M this giant machine should
be glowing in the infrared and um he
proposed that in that paper that first
paper he said this is what you should
look for and people have been doing that
people have been you know there's been a
few studies Jason Wright in particular
recently looking for Dyson spheres and
you can extend this idea to almost
anything one of the things that we've
proposed is that in a civil planet that
has uh civilization you would see in the
chemical networks in the atmospheres
you'd see evidence of the
non-equilibrium processes and their dis
a that are going on and you would be
able to look for that in the atmosphere
as an indication that there was
something going on in that planet that
was beyond just not having any life or
beyond having just a biosphere there's a
Cascade upward in sense of how much
dissipation happens because of your use
of energy okay wait a minute I want to
get back to that but but first I need to
harp on Dyson's thing because I don't
believe it I don't think it's right I
think it makes a pretty simple error uh
as long as as you have a source of
energy that is hotter than your
environment then there's useful work you
can extract from it so if you're at all
a smart technological civilization you
should Cascade the heat that you're
emitting back out in the universe all
the way down to the temperature of the
microwave background so I don't think
that Dyson Sphere should be visible at
all uh well so you want to have a
Cascade of machines but each machine is
going to have some level of dissipation
that I mean I'm not sure that you can
Harvest all of the dissipated energy I
mean I think at some point you're going
to have you're right I mean a practice I
could figure it
out I think you know it's interesting I
think I I recall papers I recall a paper
I think that was discussing about these
sort of Cascades of machines um but
ultimately right you can't you can't
Harvest at all right I mean some of it
is going to have to be dissipated you
have to harvest you can't you can't
lower your temperature below that of
your environment right right right which
I think is three degrees cevin yeah all
right so that was one thing but now that
the and I do want to get back to the
super civilizations but now you're
you're I want to hear more about this
analogous thing which I take it to be
with just the existence of life not
necessarily with technology uh and I
completely agree that you know primitive
life obeys the second law and is not
even very optimized to uh turn its its
energy into waste heat so what exactly
is the signature that you're looking for
the uh life so everybody should take a
deep
breath right all that oxygen in the
atmosphere is a consequence of this
invention about two and a half billion
years ago of a new form of
photosynthesis right um which was CH
completely changed the planet right so
so uh photosynthesis was actually not a
very efficient Affair before this
happened they it required um there to be
it was extracting iron ions that's what
it used as a you know you get in a photo
you'd move some you know iron in the
ocean around you know some molecules
around uh ions and then you'd be able to
make a sugar once uh once photosynthesis
uh once life figured out oh I can use
water as the substrate right that
changed everything because water's
everywhere now you you're done with your
rate limiting step um and so you break
apart uh water molecule use the hydrogen
as part of the molecular Machinery to
make the sugar and you burp out the
oxygen so that was an enormous change in
the Earth the planet's history right
that that the introduction of oxygen
into the whole geosphere
changed um and it eventually put the
oxygen into the atmosphere the 21% that
we have now and it's that continuous
flux of oxygen into the atmosphere is a
driver of non-equilibrium chemistry
right I mean if that oxygen went away
for whatever reasons very quickly I
don't know the exact time but you know
certainly within a million years or so
all the oxygen gets bound up with at
with rocks again and it's gone you're
back to the previous nitrogen CO2
dominated so it's both so the presence
of certain chemicals the flux of those
chemicals means that your atmospheric
state is non-equilibrium it's life
that's driving it in there and then even
more to the point this is some really
fascinating work that's going on now um
people like SAR Walker and others and um
Sarah Seager you know have been this
trying this idea of looking for agnostic
bio signatures things that don't have
anything to do with what's happened on
Earth and one of the interesting ways to
do this is looking at the again the
network property right if you of the of
the that you see in the chem the
chemical Network in the atmosphere the
network properties of who's reacting
with whom in a system where life is
pushing those chemicals into the
atmosphere is going to look very
different and they've sh there's a great
paper by Kim atall uh a few years ago
will look very different than a random
Network and so by looking at you know
who's connected to who the you know the
the degreen the degree centrality all of
these network uh topology
characteristics you can really see
differences between biology building the
network and just random or just P pure
geophysics yeah actually I'm very
sympathetic to that because anyone every
time people talk about CO2 or methane or
oxygen or whatever I'm like okay maybe
here on Earth there was a certain way
that was made but come on these
molecules are so simple that maybe
there's a different chemical process
going on we don't know about but if you
have like some very complex carbohydr
that car hydrocarbon uh I just invented
a new word a carboh hydron uh
hydrocarbons are things that life
naturally makes or even very very
complicated molecules at all that sounds
like a promising place to look but maybe
those are harder to look for I don't
know well I they will require bigger
telep sces that have longer that you
where we can you know the whole point of
a big telescope is it's a light bucket
the bigger your bucket the more light
you gather the more light you gather the
faster you can look for a spectral
feature so it is true that that but
we're again we're just starting down
this road so this idea of agnostic bio
signatures is something that really only
in the last five 10 years people have
really begun and there's been funding
for and so Network properties of one of
them looking at again this idea of
dissipation trying to calculate the the
you know how far away from you are how
far are you from the equilibrium state
of the atmosphere you know using that
metric the distance as a measure of how
much life you know dumb life or smart
life is is pushing you away but I really
love what is interesting and we're
working on this as well the whole idea
of of information architecture right
using using information theoretic uh
measures of how comp this is what
assembly theory is about that's one of
the things why you know why why those
guys were interested in assembly but
there's others of seeing like just how
how do you measure how complex this
molecule is or atom is and how much does
that allow you to say okay this could
only be produced by life or this could
only be produced by technology right
which probably can only be produced by
life right exactly so speaking of which
uh I mean let's let's finish up the uh
Advanced civilization business there's
an obvious problem Ling in the
background here we've gone 25 minutes
into the podcast without mentioning it
but where are all of these advant
civilizations uh didn't Professor fmy
point out a paradox in this way of
thinking yes the infamous fmy Paradox
what I like about the fery Paradox is
that it's the first you know it was 1950
right and so in the book you know I sort
of go through this history the the
decade of the 50s is amazing because you
start with fery then you have the Miller
uray experiment which was this first
experiment that showed like you know it
may not be that hard to start get life
started and then you end with Drake
doing his first uh SE search but the
let's so the fmy par
the is the idea that look if the stars
if if intelligent life is common and if
you if intelligent life can Trav figures
out how to travel at even a tenth of the
speed of light then basically the whole
universe should be filled or the whole
galaxy should be filled with intelligent
life they should have been able to hop
from one star system to the next and
settled and built up you know
civilization and moved on to the so that
is what we call the direct fmy Paradox
why aren't they here now so of course if
you're into UFOs the answer is clear
they are here now but if you're not into
UFOs there is an entire sort of um you
know cottage industry of people coming
up with answers to that well we're Zoo
we're being held you know uh you know
nobody's they're not contacting us
because they want to leave us alone and
watch us but I actually think and we did
a we did a whole series of papers on
this I think there's an easier answer to
this which is the debate about the firmy
Paradox was how fast does that
civilization front move right you know
is does it take in the original
calculation that Hart did of the fmy
Paradox 1975 heart showed it takes about
600,000 years if you're moving at like
0.1 c um which is very short compared to
the age of the Galaxy hence the fmy
parad and then uh Sean and others said
oh no no it's going to stall out because
of resource issues we did a simulation
we did a you know we made a little
Galaxy turning around and we did you
know the really nice simulation of
Jonathan Carol my post do former post do
ran this and what we found is yes the uh
the front travels very fast it's you
know you colonize your your Galaxy very
quickly but civil if you add the fact
that civilizations don't last forever
right I mean you know civilizations die
if you allow the civilizations to die
now you have to ask what is the steady
state occupation of the Galaxy and what
you find is you can end up with
depending on the par of your space
travel you can end up with pockets that
are
un uh un uncolonized or settled for
millions of years and those pockets it's
possible that we just live in one of
those pockets and maybe we were visited
a billion years ago and maybe there was
a civilization that was set up for you
know 10,000 years which is a lot longer
than we've lasted but all evidence of
that is gone the paper I did with Gavin
Schmidt the one on the soran hypothesis
where we showed that if there was a
civilization here 100 million years ago
there's no way to know there's no
fossils there's no the only way you can
find is to look at um look for uh
isotopic
anomalies I can't I can't let you quite
get away with that so quickly I want to
I want to hear more about this so if I
mean how big of a civilization are you
saying could have been here 100 million
years ago the size of our current
civilization easily yeah easily we're
not going to leave so so the equivalent
of of Manhattan would just be erased
from the earth in 100 it is ground down
yeah in that paper as Gavin you know you
know pointed out that the Earth's
surface gets pretty well restructured
you know after a few million years
certainly by 10 million years there
anything that was on the surface is gone
because a lot of the surface is gone
right it's been subducted and come back
up so there's not a whole lot of
pristine there's almost no pristine
surface from even you know 100 million
years ago so with that and then fossils
everyone's like well there'll be fossils
the fossil record is so incomplete very
few things get fossilized so if you had
a civilization that was worldwide and
that lasted 10,000 years that is still
so short that nothing would be you
wouldn't find anything now you know 100
million years later so that's a pretty
remarkable fact that's why we wrote that
paper is just not that there was we were
saying there was a civilization but just
like the interesting scientific question
of like could you tell and the answer is
probably not so two things come to mind
immediately but I also come up with
objections to them one is that the
chemical and Atmospheric signatures
would have been pretty enormous and the
other thing is wouldn't have had a big
effect on not by leaving fossils but by
affecting other life forms uh effects on
the biosphere that would show up in the
fossil record yeah well the first one
the the atmospheric uh record it's
really it what where you're going to
have to look for the rec for it and this
is what we did in the paper was in I can
never pronounce this Strat ography
stratag graphy Strat in the strata
you're going to look for isotopic
anomalies because the temperature went
up or the temperature went down or you
know or Plastics or and as we showed you
know 10,000 years is probably too short
to really pick out that you need there
are signals there are definitely signals
of interesting things happening but in
they're very long you know stretched
across long times and then you can find
better explanations like you know
climate change or you know uh massive
volcanic eruptions but also as we
pointed out in the paper no one's ever
actually done the kind of
highresolution uh uh studies I just
can't pronounce stre TIG rography um
that of the kind that you need so that
in that sense yeah that that's where
you're right that's where you'd have to
look up to now with what we have you
can't say there's anything but as we
that's we ended the paper like hey maybe
people should look at this more
carefully and your second point I forgot
what was your second Point causing mass
extinctions or new forer to show up or
something like that uh yeah that's an
interesting point uh we did not consider
that in the paper my guess would be but
it's only a guess is that uh you know
unless you lived for a very long time
you probably wouldn't be able to catch
that level of something so short I'm not
sure about that though I mean we are
right people would say we're driving a
mass extinction will our mass extinction
really show up or not I don't know so
that's a possibility and we'd have to
look to see if that were that work true
okay good here's my other crazy
possibility so what if civilizations
last a little bit longer than you
assumed in your paper and so but but
they're rare so it's not surprising that
we don't have one here in the Galaxy we
haven't been taken over but 1% of the
galaxies that we can see in the field
have been taken over by Advanced
civilizations is there any way we would
know that and have we looked uh people
so that idea of Galactic engineering
comes from the uh idea of the kesef
scale which we can very quickly go over
so kesef in this Golden Era of SEI right
after 1960 kesef was a Russian physicist
who propose or astrophysicist who
proposed that there were three levels of
civilizations it's a good way of
characterizing them based on their
energy use type one harvested all the
energy falling on their planet type two
harvested all the energy coming from
their star Allah a Dyson Sphere and type
three harvested all the energy of all
the stars in their Galaxy maybe even
moving the Stars around to Clump them
together sure um so no one I mean people
have not really looked for this and the
pro the reason why people have not
really looked for this is that again
there's never been any money for this
right you know like you you know to do a
search like this you need telescope time
and you need graduate students and
there's been never any funding for this
so maybe here and there people have like
tried this or that but never been a
coherent uh study of this and hopefully
now that things are changing you'll
there will be the ability some funding
to look for those kinds of like really
Galactic engineering or even planetary
engineering here's an interesting uh EXO
or tarff sorry techno signature that
Jill Tarter came up with if you found if
you looked at a solar system and saw
three planets or four planets that all
had the exact same climate that would be
a really good indication that those
Worlds at least some of those worlds had
been terraformed that's a good one yeah
that's a real I thought that was a
really clever one so you know this idea
of PL of of solar system scale
engineering or or Galactic engineering
that's a great place that's a you know a
really good place to look which you know
once we have a true program in techno
signatures we can do that but I think
that the data has already been collected
for the galaxies we have Galaxy surveys
with Spectra all take this one grad
student to take this up as a project and
uh scan through the data from I don't
know Sloan or something like that well
you have to know what you have to figure
out what exactly are you looking for I
mean because you know it's very this is
the this is always the Dilemma how do
you determine what what's a natural
signal and what's not a natural signal I
mean so you you what nobody has done
right now is articulated what explicitly
would be the signature of that kind of
engineering so with the Dyson Sphere we
say like oh look you need infrared you
need to have very bright infrared
sources um and there's been a couple of
studies of those but not much so you
know the first job is to figure out what
the Techno or bio signature is and then
go look for it um and you know you're
not going to get telescope time unless
you or even archival time right to go
look through all this unless you know
what you're looking for yeah no I I I I
do not agree I think this is this is a
very doable project you got a million
Galaxy Spectra you ask a machine
learning model to say what is there some
fraction of these that look weird in a
universally common way and then you go
back and look at those galaxies and ask
if there's anything weird looking about
them well you could do that I mean I'm
wonder I you I'm not sure if anybody has
done I mean certainly people have done
various kinds of anomaly searches for
other kinds of things like for example
the the move we have enough data about
the moon to look for any kind somebody
left something from a billion years ago
but again like you know so people have
done like have done test projects with
that like you can find you can give like
50 square miles around the uh lunar
lander and machine learning will find it
immediately be like that's different um
but I still think with the galaxies I
this be an interesting question to look
at the G you still got to figure out you
know you know just finding you could yes
you can find weird things and so youd
have a big giant box of weird things but
you know sorting out the weird from the
alien weird is yeah you got to I think
you're going to have to know what you're
looking for so I be interested to see if
anybody's tried I'm sure people have
done this just for looking for quazars
right looking for odd quazars or such
but but if you know if you'd haven't
created that category is like no these
are the things I want you to bin because
they might be aliens um I don't know if
anybody's ever done that well I guess
that's what I'm getting at is that is
that what what for all the things that
Ai and machine learning are overhyped
about uh I think one of the things that
they're pretty good at is you know not
making presumptions that humans make so
if you just asked it like is there a
systematic way that some fraction of
galaxies are weird I'm not saying it's
Ali like maybe you make some other
epocal astrophysical Discovery right but
but just ask it that and then if it says
yes these 3% of galaxies are really
weird then go back and look at them and
then you know rather than presuming what
the signature would be yeah I'd have to
say I mean it feels like somebody for
for reasons that have nothing to do with
aliens people must have done that right
I mean you saw that you know it's
interesting one when we Tabby star or or
ban star that star that people thought
maybe we'd found a Dyson swarm around
was sort of exactly that there was a
pipeline from the Kepler data that was
you know identified transits
automatically and then it would spit out
the ones that were like I don't know
what this is this one doesn't make any
sense to me right and then there was a
citizen science project that actually
identified bjoy and stars being like wow
these don't look anything like a planet
and that is where you know for I mean
there were many possibilities a alien
mega structures was at the bottom of the
list but for a while people were like
whoa this is the kind of thing we'd
expect if it was alien so that was an
example doing exactly what you think
there's a machine learning algorithm for
these transits and then it spits out the
ones that like this doesn't look like
anything I understand but you know one
thing I want to emphasize is from my
perspective I'm not a huge fan when it
comes to techn signature
of like the galactic engineering or the
because that assumes a level of
technology and a level of organization
and a level of cosmic coherence to a
civilization that I'm not sure is
possible because if the speed of light
is really a a boundary then you know it
may be very hard to have Galactic
Civilizations right if it takes unless
you're very longlived right unless
you're species very long lived you
should be you're you're super
technologically advanced why should you
have not conquered death
uh that's a whole other topic not sure
about I mean right this gets into his
right sure if they're or if they're
machines right if they are you know if
they're um uh if they if they're fully
silicon right and I talk about that in
the book that's a real how long is the
biological era how long till we are
replaced by our Robot Masters um but I
still I you know there's that that
running in that direction still makes
less sense to me than let's just look at
the planets right planets you know let's
just it's let's just Eaves drop on the
planets that we can now because we
couldn't do that before right and we can
just look at these planets and look to
see whether again yeah anomalies whether
there's anything happening on the
planets that is weird um and we couldn't
do that before so looking at G looking
at that scale of Galactic engineering
which is just we just don't know whereas
we at least have one example of of a
species of you know life forming on a
planet that that species becoming
intelligent and and changing the planet
at least you know we have the existence
proof for that one so that and we
couldn't do that before and so that's
one I'm most excited about so what are
we doing to look for life elsewhere I
mean obviously we're probably doing
something very different to look for
intelligent life than to look for
microbial life but we have this image of
jod foster sitting at a radio telescope
uh wearing earphones probably we're we
have other techniques rather than that
by now that's the main emphasis for me
that I'm trying to get people to
understand is that that is what I call
Classic and it's you know great idea uh
um but we've moved that now becomes just
a subset of this much larger array of
possibilities which was just never
possible before one of the thing about
the classic seti that Frank Drake did is
you kind of needed a beacon you needed
somebody sending a message at you
focusing their their radio energy
because if not if you were doing it you
know into the all Sky You' need
something that was so bright it was a
star right so that assumed there was
this whole
sort of assumption that like yeah they
want to contact you they're interested
in contact whereas now what's possible
with jwst Etc is that I call them
metabolic techn signatures it's just the
civilization or the biosphere just going
about its business we don't have to
really care whether they're trying to
contact us they're just doing what
they're doing and we're like detectives
on a stake out with our you know in our
cars with our cold cups of coffee and
our crappy donuts and we're just
watching the planet or this or the
Stellar system and we're just looking
for them going about their business and
that wasn't possible before and now it
is so when it comes to life we can look
for these bio signatures things like
oxygen or um uh you know the network
properties of the chemicals that we
talked about before when it comes to
techno signatures we can look for we
actually have the capacity we just wrote
a paper on this we could find
chlorofluorocarbons in a in a planet 40
at our level at our level Earth's level
of chloro for car chloro Floral carbons
which if people don't know that's the
chemical we banned because it was
destroying the ozone yeah uh but it's
it's absolutely not natural there's no
way we know to produce uh cfc's
naturally and we showed in a paper that
the James Webb Space Telescope with a
couple of assumptions and about a few
hundred hours of uh of of observing time
could detect chlorofluorocarbons at our
level certainly at five or 10 times our
level um in a planet that was 40 light
years away so we can detect atmospheric
either pollutants I'm putting that in
quotes because you may put
chlorofluorocarbons into your atmosphere
on purpose if you want to terraform Mars
cfc's are a great idea they're very good
greenhouse gases we can there's been a
paper that shown you could detect City
Lights artificial illumination uh there
was a paper that showed you could look
for if you were deploying solar panels
on a large scale there's a imprint in
the reflected light the reflectivity
changes we call that the ultraviolet
Edge um and that would be detectable
just like plants actually there's a red
Edge the reflectance of Earth already
you can see it all the plants all the
chlorophyll puts a reflectance Edge at
the in the red so sorry sorry say say
what is it doing they're they're
absorbing red or they're reflecting red
what what exactly is that they are it it
is a change in because of what it's
absorbing in more in the blue green it
adds a change in the reflectance of
light at the red light so you see climb
at the red okay more red gotcha yeah
because you're absorbing the blue green
um so that is a that's already we've
shown that Earth has that somebody from
uh you know somebody looking at Earth
Somebody looking at Earth for the last
two billion years could tell Earth was
an inhabited planet right that's what's
incredible um so yeah all we have all
these things are now possible and the
that's really what the book is about in
the next 10 20 30 years we're gonna have
data I don't know what it's going to say
but we're going to have data relevant to
this rather than yelling at each other
about our opinions man which is pretty
much what the last 2005 00 years hey
it's also what podcasts do I don't want
you to be badmouthing yelling at each
others with our opinions but uh so which
of these are going on are these programs
or are they just like individual um
investigators proposing to NASA to
collect some data no it's it's it's all
in so NASA has is funding astrobiology
in a big way and again this the decadal
survey really shows right the decal
survey said look the next 12 billion
telescope you build is going to be about
life it's going to be tuned to find life
and that is just the tip of the iceberg
of showing that NASA is all in in terms
of its funding there's a number of
different programs that speak to
habitability to bio signatures to
exobiology our grant is in the
exobiology program but there's lots and
lots of others uh that NASA is funding
everything from doing developing more
powerful methods of atmospheric
characterization to studying uh the the
the Cycles or the the uh evolution of
atmospheres that's another project I'm
involved in um many of the planets we're
going to be looking at are going to be
close to their Stars what are called M
dwarf planets these are the planets
we're going to look for are the mo are
orbiting the most abundant type of star
which is not the sun the sun is not the
most abundant star it's a it's a redder
smaller mass star and the habitable zone
for those are very close to the star and
it's possible that you just you know
there there's so much um Uh crap coming
off the star because of solar flares
that maybe the atmospheres don't last so
you know you got no asphere no
habitability so that's a whole program
so NASA across a wide range of fronts is
funding
astrobiology um as a one of its major
programs now it's one of their principal
programs and there is this opposite
thing we can try to do which is to draw
attention to ourselves right to beam
signals out to the world or to send uh
probes out there with record players on
them um are we still doing that and is
that a good idea uh I am not a fan of
medy of messaging estri terrial
intelligence I have watched too much
science fiction exactly to think that's
a good I just really and the main
problem with it uh is that who gets to
do it the idea that some astronomer with
access to a radio telescope beams a
powerful signal you know to some distant
star system just seems like
of of course we should consider the
possibility that's a bad idea right we
may de decide okay we're wrong but you
have to consider the possibility and so
I think there really needs to be some
kind of international body that debates
this makes it a public debate and so we
can decide whether we want to do
this yeah I'm also of the opinion that
maybe they would help us maybe they
would hurt us let's see first if we can
figure some stuff out for ourselves
before we draw our attention to this
vastly more powerful Intergalactic force
that may be for good or for evil okay um
well how optimistic are you about this I
mean it is certainly possible that the
solution to the fmy Paradox is that life
happens on one planet in 10 to the 100
and therefore it's just us do we have
any way of competently estimating How
likely we're going to succeed here the
best we can do I think is the word I'm
going to quote my own work here but
Woody Sullivan and I a bunch of years
back did this paper where we said look
you know there's the Drake equation
right the Drake equation the time
honored equation which allows you to
like plug in values that you've made up
and try and answer how many uh
civilizations there are in the galaxy
and Woody and I asked look we've got
this exoplanet data what can we use it
for right how can it's got to tell us
something about the question about extra
about
civilization and and so what we're able
to do is you know it's always with
science it's the question you can answer
not the question you want to answer oh
yeah and so what we were able to do was
we were able to manipulate the Drake
equation and answer this question how
bad does the per Planet uh o odds for
forming a civilization have to be to
make us to make us the only ones in the
universe right the only time it's ever
happened in the observable universe and
that answer turns out to be 10 to the US
22 right now you can say well what does
that mean like we don't have you know is
10 Theus 22 big or is it small and for
this then you look at the literature
right because people have been trying to
theoretically calculate or estimate in
one way or the other how uh what the
odds of uh what this this per Planet
probability should be and then that's
where you break up into pessimists and
optimists I talk about that in the book
right and so in general the pessimists
were like 10 to the Theus 15 right and
even the most pessimistic of all
pessimists which was this calculation
that was done and all suddenly now my
brain's going to go blank on the author
um uh but where they said absolutely it
was a really interesting uh uh
calculation that they did uh kind of
based on the anthropic principle but
they said look the you know if it's 10
the minus 20 we get 10 the minus 20 for
the probability of forming a
civilization per planet and that's so
small that you know there can never be
any civilizations around our number was
10us 22 which would mean that there's
100 civilizations before us I mean even
if we can't observe them it means it's
happened before so the only thing I
think that's useful about what we did is
it showed we called it the pessimism
line it showed the difference between
really what you mean by pessimism and 10
the minus 22 is small enough because
what it is means that there's been 10 to
the 22 experiments right every habitable
zone planet is an experiment in life and
civilizations and in order for us to be
the only ones it means every one of
those experiments fail and I think then
it sort of falls to the pessimist to say
well what is it it happened with us but
what happen why what is what are the
filters that keep it h from happening
anywhere else so that that's kind of my
that's what I would say where I'm at
that so I completely understand where
the number 10us 21 or 10-22 comes from
that's the reciprocal of the number of
planets that might beable so that that's
fine but I have no idea of how people
are estimating the probability that
Planet forms life in the first place
forget about intelligent life for
civilizations like where where are we
getting that from well uh some people do
combinatorics they say okay how long do
you have to wait for a DNA to you know
form by bouncing around other people
looked at um um the number of species
that formed and their durations I think
that's what went into the because he was
actually asking about intelligence other
people will use um the kind of a basian
analysis of when did life appear on
Earth which is pretty quickly right so
you know with the the planet's 4.5
billion years old by 3.8 billion years
we've got the zircons I love that the
little zircons whatever that that's such
a great word that indicate that there
may have already been life on Earth so
people have various methods and of
course you're absolutely right if you're
going to say it all seems like you know
magic and um smoke and mirrors it is I
mean it's very hard to do this abono uh
but people have tried various ways and
so there is a literature there is a
literature of people trying tring very
clearly to do this and one of our points
in this was that like even the most
pessimistic of pessimists actually turns
out to be an optimist based on the
number we got uh that's is very
surprising to me like no one has said
maybe the probability is 10 the minus 40
of of Life forming we to know so little
about it yeah there's only one and that
was the combinatorics argument but
people you know that the problem with
that was it was shown very quickly that
you don't need to assemble DNA from
scratch so that argument was sort of
went by the wayside and people yeah but
the fact that life started fairly early
on Earth is essentially meaningless to
me because you have to conditionalize on
the fact that life already exists we
already know that so it's not telling me
very much so I I'm not saying that the
number is small I'm just saying is there
any principled reason to estimate that
number big or small I mean how advanced
are we in coming up with theories for
how life formed yeah uh there I would
say we're still I mean in especially in
terms of being able to get a number that
you'd like I think we don't have it yet
I mean our Pro we've made enormous
progress in understanding the evolution
of life on earth and the possible R
routes for a
biogenesis um but still being able to
use that to get you'll see the there's a
huge literature on this of people
arguing back and forth but I don't think
there's anything of the kind you want
and in some sense that's why all of
these estimations you know we just got
to go look you know we just got to go
look and find and the Beautiful Thing is
we find one other example
of even microbial life and all bets are
off right now you're what is your
personal feeling about right here in the
solar system are you optimistic about
finding something uh yeah I am I am just
because God I was just looking at this
yesterday for this project we're
involved in on looking at planetary the
interaction between planetary interiors
and their atmospheres and the moons all
those moons out there are like there's
so much water so we are seeing so many
subsurface oceans on these moons so the
the moons around the Gas Giants and the
ice giants were just formed with lots
and lots of water and it turns out that
they have significant oceans hiding
beneath either layers of ice like uh
Europa has a uh I think like a 10 mile
or six mile thick layer of ice which is
sitting on top of a 60 mile deep ocean
there's more water on the the moon of
your Europa which is about Earth the
size of Earth's moon then on Earth all
of Earth's oceans uh and it is just one
of a handful on get on the order of five
10 moons all of out there all of which
have significant subsurface oceans so I
think there is a lot of possibilities
out there and the next you know if we
manage to make it through everything
we're going through right now the future
there's a lot of interesting
possibilities of what could be living
what might have started in those oceans
is your is Europa your favorite Target
Europa is my favorite Target because
it's so cool but I mean that's probably
just my bias because in you know I'm old
enough to remember when Europa was
discovered to be uh an ocean Moon yeah
but antilus which is orbiting Saturn is
a really interesting one because there
you're getting the the uh geers you're
getting the water sprayed out into uh
into space and you can fly things
through that water that's how we
discovered the water was brine very
salty very good for getting life started
so um I love Europa cuz it's so cool but
I think probably is you know once we
start getting out into the outer solar
system we may find other ones that are
better the search how much Credence
should we put on truly wacky forms of
life like I'm sure you've read Dragon's
egg by Robert forward where there was
life on the surface of a neutron star or
the black cloud by hoil where it was
some giant molecular cloud like how
open-minded should we be about the forms
life could take uh I'm not wild about
those especially you know in doing this
work I've had to look at a lot of The
evolutionary biology literature you know
and one problem with the black cloud is
how did it evolve like how did you get
the processes of darwinian evolution to
work for these interstellar clouds so I
tend to think it's maybe my bias but I
think it's much better especially
because we can now we don't need to
think about you know New Life on neutron
stars we have finally the possibility of
going out and looking for the kind of
life we understand which is made out of
molecular modules right we our
understanding of life is that it is
principally driven by molecular
Shenanigans you know you need these
modules that can build bigger things
that can then take on different purposes
and that can hold energy sorry um hold
information have these gorgeous
information architectures associated
with and I just think that right now
because we can do it that's where we
should be spending our time that's more
likely um and we finally can do it and
there's a rich literature Rich
understanding of evolution in a very
generic sense that we can apply okay but
don't come to me when the giant
Interstellar Cloud gets mad at us for
not taking it seriously and dissing it
yeah it's wrath okay all right good so
we've gone this long without seriously
confronting the whole UFO mess every
every 6 months there's a UFO report and
I go on the internet and say yeah it's
not really UFO it's not it's not aliens
and I always get like well oh but
there's going to be a report coming out
in the next 6 months that will reveal
everything and you will be ashamed and
so far it it has not happened to me I
mean I don't know what your experience
here is pretty much the same thing uh I
wanted in the book to cover UFOs about a
third of the book is about UFOs um and
uaps because I wanted people to
understand how to separate the wheat
from the Chafe right so the history of
UFOs is one of you know people seeing
things I'll never tell somebody they
didn't see something I wasn't there
right but science is about public
knowledge and science has very high
standards of evidence for good reason
it's why the cell phone works it's why
your knee replacement surgery doesn't
kill you um and so a claim to that you
know that something is related to life
somewhere else in the universe is a huge
claim and you're going to have to do a
lot better than fuzzy photographs and
personal stories no matter how
compelling those personal stories are so
as I always like to say there is nothing
right now that would link any there's no
evidence that would link any UFO UAP to
the something beyond Earth Technology we
should do the search I am all forward
you know had the NASA panel I think you
know people are so interested in this um
I think we should do a full open
transparent search and we'll see what
happens uh and also I'm glad the pilots
have been able to come through you I've
talked at length with Ryan Graves the
pilot um for you know one of the one of
the Navy pilots and what I like about
him he's like very agnostic he's like
look I saw this it was behaving in ways
that no jet I've been around a lot of
jets that no jet ever you know moved um
but you know I need you guys to tell me
what it is he's not saying it's aliens
and he recognizes the fact that just
seeing something is not proof right you
need and this I have so I have a whole
chapter where I go through like what
would you need okay if you really wanted
to do a scientific search what would you
need you'd need to build your own
instruments so you understand them you
need a rational search strategy and then
you need some way to harvest all this
data and and comb through it so as you
said what the problem with UFOs and uaps
is that the history of it is full of
conspiracy theories and hoaxes where
everybody's always telling us next year
you know where the data is going to be
released it never happens um and so
people need to really understand they
need to a healthy do of skepticism as I
like to say you should think about UFOs
and the claims made about them as if you
had just got into Time Square and some
guy says hey man I've got a $100 Rolex
do you want to buy it right is it really
a Rolex probably not but you know seen
it with my own
eyes and what would you say about the
idea that from the aliens point of view
you know talk to us about the
plausibility of extraterrestrial
Advanced civilizations coming to visit
us and being susceptible to having fuzzy
photographs of themselves taken or or
crashing in Nevada
yeah well this is the real problem with
it it's like look and this is what I
want people to understand who are
interested in UFOs because listen people
who really are interested in UFOs for
whatever reason I think cool look I'm
interested in Aliens I love aliens right
but you know if you really if you don't
want to just believe if you want to know
then you've got to kind of think the
science through right you don't want to
you know I can write a science fiction
story you can write a science fiction
story that's not what we're interested
in so the idea let's first of all take
the whole a that you saw lights in the
sky right CU apparently the aliens don't
want to land on the White House lawn and
be like yo we're here uh so that means
they're trying to hide and therefore
they suck at it because like what you
can't turn the lights off like you know
there's this you know there's a cloaking
device that just doesn't seem to work or
they've got a bunch of you know
13-year-olds flying these things who've
stolen it from their parents so there's
just that sort of coherent part of the
argument it just doesn't make sense that
they don't want to be revealed but they
keep showing themselves and then there's
the blurry photographs photography has
gotten obviously a lot better since 1947
with our first the that's the first real
uh UFO sighting that that catches on and
yet it's always blurry photographs it's
always blurry photographs and remember
the Chinese spy balloon right there was
a there is a picture I think it's a
selfie that the pilot you know one of
the the the You2 Pilots is taking and
he's holding the camera over his head
and you can see his helmet then you see
the Chinese spy balloon and you can see
the rivets on the solar panels below the
the payload it's like come on why aren't
there thousands of pictures like this so
there's just and then there's the
crashes obviously the crashes like the
things able to get through Interstellar
space and it crashes you know once it
gets here because it got hit by
lightning that was part of the story in
the Ros I mean what they're sending us
there 1987 Dodge omnis right you
know so it's just I don't again I don't
want to make fun of you know people but
I just think you have to sort of like
you have to ask for a coherent
consistent scientifically um integrated
story and these are the kind of things
that tell you that this just doesn't
make much sense I mean that's a good
line you're selling us Adam but it's
exactly what an agent of the deep state
would be telling us if they wanted to
hide the truth so I I have to maintain
my skepticism so far somebody said that
to me on Twitter one time and I was like
well if I am where's the check from the
deep State because yeah I got more Mets
paraphernalia to to to to buy and then
he said hey everybody you can see this
is why this guy isn't trustworthy and I
said you know what that's what my kid
said when I hid their Halloween candy in
2002 this guy's not
trustworthy but it does I mean maybe
this is a good place to wrap up because
it takes us back to the beginning where
you where you mentioned the almost
tension between the science of this and
the science fiction of it right I mean
it goes in both ways there are
enthusiasts
who are very invested in the existence
and discovery of alien life whether it's
microbes or or civilizations and then
there's a reaction against that that
maybe makes it hard to take it seriously
how do we balance those those two very
natural human impulses yeah I think you
know the whole point this is the beauty
of science right science teaches you how
to change your mind right I'm open I'm
literally doing a calculation now with
some friends where we're looking at how
long would the lunar lander be visible
how long on the moon before this process
called gardening which is micr
meteorites just eroding that's how the
regolith ended up being such so fine
because look I'm willing to consider
that somebody came through a billion
years ago and you know left their lunch
PA or whatever or a monolith who knows
um so you know the I'm willing to
consider the possibility if the data for
the uaps let's say we do a UAP study and
we do see things making right-hand turns
at mock 500 right I you know if the data
is good I'll be like okay here we go
right so the beauty of science is it
shows you how to change your mind with
honor right um and I think that's what
separates I've met a lot of people in
the UFO community and UAP community and
there are those who are totally have
that they're like look this is what I
believe or I'm I'm interested in I think
it could be but the data will if the
data shows me something different that's
where I'll go and what I found is
there's also people not like this I was
just on the tamrind Hall Show and The
thing was about UFOs and then I would
talked to some of the people behind the
before we went on and some of them I
brought them and they were like yeah
look if the data goes that way and there
was one person in particular unnamed who
I said well listen if we were able to
show that those things those pictures
you were showing are natural phenomena
what would you do and they were like oh
no no no I know that they were right so
it's like okay now it's a religion right
right right so the point about science
fiction is important though because I
still a lot of my ideas come from good
science fiction a lot of things I'm
interested in to pursue Kim Stanley
Robinson there's a couple ideas he had
that drove me to research projects um so
I think there's a very important
interchange between science fiction and
this field particularly when it comes to
civilizations and it's that scientists
are not the best at asking some of the
questions you need to especially about
civilizations right we're not trained in
sociology or anthropology or there's a
way in which you need a our imaginations
to be lifted out of the kind of way we
think of things scientists think of
things and so I've always wanted to have
like a conference where we asked some of
the best science fiction writers we P
bunch of scientists posed questions to
them and have them tell us stories you
know that are focused that we might be
able to might be able to drive us so I
think there is a very important
interchange between science fiction and
this field and thinking about aliens but
the point is to not get lost right is to
understand when something is just a
science fiction story un untethered to
reality or to and and when when because
of course with science what we need is
we need constrained imagination right we
have our imaginations let our
imaginations go but it's got to be
constrained by the laws of physics and
biology and evolution even if we're
going to extrapolate them so I think
that's the balance we have to find well
it I do I completely agree with you that
um
the the little nudge to the imagination
that science fiction can give us uh is
wonderfully valuable and we should
cherish it at the same time I I worry a
little bit you know I just had Zack and
Kelly weiner Smith on the show talking
about the challenges we would face if we
wanted to colonize Mars or the moon or
something like that I'm thinking also of
just how people think about the future
of AI or Interstellar travel um
and there there's there's this idea that
science fiction authors do the best they
can but they're telling stories and they
can sometimes give us the wrong
impression about how easy certain things
are right I mean no one predicted the
internet very effectively like they may
have mentioned the possibility of of
computers and being connected but no one
as far as I know a hundred years ago was
correctly predicting what the world
would look like now
so on the one hand I want to caution
against taking science fiction too
seriously but on the other hand is there
a way that scientists can loosen up a
bit and put their brains to work in
thinking more carefully about the future
because I feel like we're in this
dichotomy between either thinking in
science fictiony terms or like
scientists saying if I can't build an
experiment that tests it in the next
five years that I'm not interested yeah
that's a great question I think there is
that space and I think that's one of the
things that makes techno signatures this
field that I'm in so interesting and
again I want you to recognize like while
bio signatures is a very
well-established field in astrobiology
technos signatures is new I think
there's like AR Grant and one other
because NASA is still a little bit
hesitant like you know aliens alien
civilizations is that really you know
but so I think the really fascinating
thing about techno signatures is this
attempt to systematize Futures right to
ask to use that constrainted imagination
to really loosen up to have some tools
at our disposal um but also loosen up
and and that really requires discussions
with it's got to be interdisciplinary
like what the really exciting thing
about technos signatures in in SII you
know I don't really use the word SII
many anymore because I think carries a
different kind of connotation but is Teo
signatures is that you got to talk to
biologists you've got to talk to
anthropologists you you know what is
technology how do we even Define
technology one of the things there is a
um there was a document that was done
called the indigenous critique of SII
and it was a bunch of indigenous
Scholars looking at the history of seti
and saying like here's a bunch of stuff
you guys haven't thought of you because
Siti was basically was a you know it was
a group of men basically you know all
sort of coming from the similar
background and they were doing great
work but of course they were limited
right if you're going to think about the
wide possibility of civilizations
probably having just one kind of human
being from one socioeconomic group is
probably not the best thing and so I
really love even though I didn't
necessarily agree with everything in the
Indigenous critique I found it really
open my mind right it allowed me to
consider other things and that's kind of
what we have to do it can't just be scci
it's got to be scientists in dialogue
with or can't be just physicists and
astronomers uh alone we've got to be in
dialogue with other scientists and the
humanities and and see how we can
constrain but still expand that's good
and so I I should just stop it there
because that was such an eloquent
statement but I have one more question
for you it's a softball don't worry uh
because I don't want people to you know
we're talking about this pretty
dispassionately but I think you're
making the case pretty effectively that
this is a prospect it might not happen
within our lifetimes but it could that
we could actually detect for even
forgetting about civilizations we could
detect life on another planet in a in a
kind of somewhat realistic way and you
said you know at the beginning that this
would be a big deal let's just sit and
marinate in how big a deal it would be
it would be a hugely big deal yeah yeah
and I think it would be a hugely big
deal for two reasons let's take life
just like you know dumb life if we even
found microbes the amazing thing look
we're both theoretical physicists right
and you know black holes are awesome
stars are awesome comets are awesome but
life is weird right life is a physical
system that you know goes beyond itself
it creates it innovates it does stuff
that no other system that we know of can
do and as if we as as for right now it
seems like we're an accident as far as
we know we're an accident it's the only
time it's happened in the entire
universe you know which would be really
weird so to find just one example that
has happened somewhere else would sort
of blow the doors off that and I think
we'd recognize that this incredible
creative capacity is something the
universe does it didn't just happen here
once by mistake it's part of the
universe this creative ongoing you know
uh um expansion of possibilities that is
evolution is something that could be
happening all over the universe and then
who knows how far it goes right you know
especially once you get to intelligence
or you don't even need to have the kind
of intelligence we have like the idea of
liquid brains like who knows what life
you know how life engages with the rest
of the physical world so that's number
one we would become part of this
community of life and that would reorder
I think everything about the way we
think of ourselves in the universe part
two is if we found a civilization it
would tell us something very important
we all know well not we all know but
like the people who are paying attention
as far as I'm concerned know that like
we Face a lot of challenges there's some
existential challenges to human
civilization not to human beings I don't
think we're ever going to go extinct or
not anytime soon but like this Global
civilization we all depend on from
climate change to nuclear war to possib
maybe AI you know it's not clear we're
going to be here in 200 years in this
form and so finding one other example of
a technological civilization would show
like okay somebody made it right it is
possible to do this because right now we
don't know whether or not um uh
sustainable long-term civilizations are
even a thing the universe does right
maybe like there are no sustainable
long-term civilizations so finding one
would show us like okay somebody made it
and that would be like an existence
proof and I think it would give us hope
so to close this up I will say when
people say oh but it's not gonna be that
it's Not Gon to matter that much it's
you're gonna find life 40 light years
away who cares and I like to bring up
the cernic revolution right because in
1400 everybody went all the smart people
went to bed going like oh look you know
tomorrow the sun's going to rise over
the horizon because the Earth's the
center of the universe and the Sun goes
around the earth 200 years later all the
educated people were like Oh look The
Horizon tomorrow morning The Horizon's
going to roll down and the sun's gonna
appear to you and that simple a nothing
changed right but that simple
astronomical fact was implicated in the
Renaissance was implicated in the
enlightenment was even implicated in the
Protestant Reformation right it became a
building block in this profound
transformation and how human beings
understood each other and I think the
discovery of life no matter what kind it
is will be the cernic revolution times a
thousand it'll just rewire how we
understand ourselves that's a good
science fiction plot we discover the
existence of intelligent life elsewhere
we don't even get to talk to it but it
changes our civilization here in a
dramatic way right it leads to that
along with maybe other things that are
happening to us because we are facing
like we have a problem with the
biosphere it's clear the bi you know
we're the biosphere is about to get rid
of us right and so maybe the discovery
of life elsewhere sort of you know we
need this new understanding of our place
on the planet and maybe that would be
part of it you know sometimes shaking
things up is a good thing so Adam Frank
thanks for your contributions to doing
exactly that and thanks for being on the
mindscape podcast thank you Sean this is
really
[Music]
fun
la